[Musique]
nos vélos chine est un immense pays
épris collins triste ou d'antoine le
feraient des mémoires nand est
frustrante brief free le fruit d'un
effort de tf1
oui nous avions rencontré samira et rami
à plusieurs reprises en 2011 et 2012
il faisait partie des milliers de jeunes
qui ont occupé la place tahrir pendant
des mois après la chute d'hosni moubarak
pourchassés par l'armée arrêtez et
torturez le pays
samira n'est pas seulement battue elle
subit un test de virginité d'une grande
violence et leurs parts et poursuit ses
bourreaux et contre toute attente le
tribunal oblige l'armée à cesser ces
tests en janvier 2012 malgré la torture
et le harcèlement des services secrets
samira et rami sont encore remplis
d'espoir l'étudiant était devenu une
icône de la place tahrir en composant
une chanson sur la démocratie
[Musique]
sokolo dit sentir autochtone et anti une
offre autant démocratique
amy a fui l'egypte en 2014 après
l'élection du général al sisi qui a
intensifié la répression
il vit aujourd'hui entre la suède et la
finlande où il continue de chanter la
révolution selon mena
jamais il a offert ce concert à helsinki
le 24 janvier pour souligner les 10 ans
de la révolution et encourager ses amis
restés en egypte
[Musique]
nos enfants
ça me ravit toujours au caire où elle
est encore surveillé par des agents du
renseignement pour éviter d'aboutir en
prison elle n'a pas accordé d'entrevue
depuis 2012
pourquoi prendre le risque de nous
parler aujourd'hui
demain
rami vient de publier ce vidéoclip pour
dénoncer les conditions de vie dans les
prisons égyptiennes qui jugent inhumain
c'est un pas et âme écrit derrière les
barreaux par un tir ami
galal el bahari et six autres personnes
ont été incarcérées en 2018 après avoir
participé à la création d'une chanson et
d'une vidéo de rami qui critiquait le
régime
[Musique]
le réalisateur de la vidéo est mort en
prison l'an dernier probablement des
suites d'une négligence médicale est
libre adios amigo dénonce l'étouffement
de tout espace politique
qu'à cela ne tienne et s'est même
présenté aux dernières élections
législatives
l'automne dernier comme candidate
indépendante sur cette affiche
elle plaide pour une citoyenneté
démocratique de la bête
ottawa le 11 février 2011
après 18 jours de révolte hosni moubarak
démissionne
ces jeunes n'oublieront jamais la force
qu'ils ont ressenti collectivement en
voyant que la volonté populaire pouvait
faire tomber un dictateur tout puissant
[Applaudissements]
les événements
[Musique]